c'est difficile de nous dire que il faut
ouvrir les écoles pour l'éducation ce
qui est normal et les fermer à nouveau
fait les élections alors personnellement
d'exactement la mer sa première fois
donc cette fois-ci qu'on vous sera prêt
ce que nous voulons c'est installer le
plus vite possible nos métropoles nos
intercommunalités commandé pour qu'elle
puisse participer de l'effort qu'on va
de me contacter pour nous demander à ce
que les collectivités locales c'est 70%
aujourd'hui de l'investissement public
il faut que ce soit au rendez vous on
est prêt à l'être à certaines conditions
nous on est prêts à l'être on le sera
que s'il est validé démocratiquement moi
je me sens je me sens pas capable
démocratiquement de prendre des des
engagements sans informer de l'onction
du suffrage universel